how are you both doing
hey steve how are you man listen i'm
talking to you two about this movie it's
a [ __ ] good day
i mean just just point blank um i want
to jump in because i got a lot of
questions and i really want to say
congratulations on this movie
um scripts like this do not come along
that often
and i'm really curious what you gave
david
to let you be a part of the film how did
you bribe them
[Music]
yeah look man i totally agree with you i
was totally enthralled with this
script it had me in a spell afterwards
you know
i just was drawing so many parallels to
my i was just i it kept creeping up in
my
days after reading it and i got on a
call with him and i
i was pestering my agents a lot
beforehand but somehow as soon as i got
on with him
we clicked into this amazing kind of
conversation
and rapport and i i guess somehow
magically the desperation had
disappeared and we were
just two guys really chatting for like
hours and and we really got along and
maybe that
came across as quite cool i don't know
but um yeah i
yeah i was very lucky to get when i
found out that david was making this
film and that he was going to send it to
me i was just like
i kind of was almost willing just to
send an
email back and look i'll just do it and
then i'll read it afterwards
i mean i'll do it i won't shoot it and
then read it afterwards
i'll just say yes and then i'll go and
read the script i just felt like he's
somebody who
um he creates these very different
worlds this very different movies and i
really
uh kind of really impressed and
intrigued by a filmmaker
that doesn't just keep running down the
same road
um so i knew that there was going to be
something really special and unique
about it and to just participate and
watch that happen was going to be
very special in and of itself the fact
that the character was really cool and
duplicitous made it all the more
exciting uh there is so much to love in
this movie
but i am curious what are you most
excited for people to see
in the film talking fox
[Laughter]
oh look i'm most excited i'm excited for
people to see what's sort of like an
unfolding kind of moving painting
you know the the visuals in this film
are extraordinary
um i challenge anybody to know where
it's headed unless they've
specifically read the poem and have at
least some lock on it
but then this is seen through the eyes
of david um
i'm really excited for people to to
understand why he held off
on showing this in the cinema and not
not really seeing it on a stream
ah man there's so much to it i think um
yeah the story is just so unique and i i
think uh
like joel said every frame is really a
painting um
and it it's so vast and psychological at
the same time
it's it's so unique it's hard to kind of
pinpoint one specific moment you know
this character goes on this journey and
collides with all these really
interesting odd characters you know are
they real are they there are they a
manifestation of his own ego i don't
know
but it kind of um it's hard to you know
there's talking foxes giants and
magical axes i i don't know
listen i love learning about the behind
the scenes of the making of a movie
stuff that you're not going to read in
any notes or whatever um
what do you think might surprise people
to learn about the making of this film
i mean really the extent david went to
to achieve some of
you know some of those compositions like
we were really the whole crews were
traveling for hours in the morning and
then they would you know be trudging
with wellies across streams and
you know there's pulley systems around
tree trunks to get camera equipment up
you know these kind of crazy slopes to
get this one shot you know
and it really paid off like you went to
extreme lengths to
to really capture some of this um uh
nature and all its glory
i've shot in ireland before there's you
know there used to be a
billboard up in new zealand as a tourism
thing that said
um you know what come to new zealand
they they haven't taken down the sets of
uh middle earth yet
you know new zealand and ireland is very
similar i mean
you you probably watch this film and
think that it's
loaded up with visual effects yes there
are visual effects complementing what's
already there
but the backdrops the sort of scale of
this film is
is uh is mostly in camera um
and i think that that's an extraordinary
thing to keep in mind while you're
watching the channel
for both of you what do you think it is
about this poem and story
that has stood for 600 plus years you
know and it resonated with so many
people
it's the divide that exists between the
thing that we say we are
or the thing that we hope to impress
upon the world as
an identifier of who we are versus what
we
really think of ourselves and
bringing those two things together means
that we have to ask ourselves a lot of
questions about what is
what is honor what is strength what is
masculinity in the case of men at least
what are the missed definitions of it
and and what how can we go about
matching those two things up
with integrity and i think that's an
incredibly
uh constant and timeless idea doesn't
need horses and swords to to for us to
look back in time to really
relate to that but um it's cool that we
do
i think everyone has an ambition
everyone has a dream
um and uh it's just about how you can
maintain joel use the word integrity
that's what david said when we first
spoke it's a young man's journey to
integrity but trying to withhold that
integrity on that journey to whatever
that successes you want to achieve
you know in in this film's term we're
talk you know we're talking about
chivalry codes like honor and
truth and cowardice and you know all
these kind of
nightly attributes but actually you can
distill it down to
you know our journeys today you know if
you want to reach success do you do it
being a good person can you maintain
that goodness in your in your
in your you know journey with you know
with your own ambitions
i think that's really relevant for
everyone i think you know um and also
you know be careful what you wish for
you know this guy romanticized this
nightly quest
and actually very soon he realizes that
it's so it's
it's it's brutalized along the way it's
it's really
it's it's a it's a hard journey to to
reach there and it is it all you made it
out to be if you were to achieve that
on that note i need to stop and again
i'm just going to say congratulations
i am also really looking forward to your
directorial debut dev
and obi-wan uh is another thing i'm
looking forward to
thank you throwing that out there listen
congrats guys have a great day
good to see you man